I wonder given the famine the same in
the famine the babe in the hoof and
imminent family good with the demon the
battles at Mema Network hey what is
going on YouTube now you know me there's
not that many things in this world that
could really rustle up my feathers like
it used to is half my content about me
screaming about [ __ ]
yes but the fact is shut the [ __ ] up but
I'm gonna take this time to tell you
guys this story about something that
really got under my skin and it happened
to be at a car dealership am i planning
to get a new car yes I am but I have to
tell you guys something I'm not really
that big of a car guy I really don't buy
unnecessary things probably the only
thing I bought in excess with shoes
which I sold most of them anyways now
and that's why you guys always leave
comments about me wearing the same [ __ ]
cuz I'm that's right I read the comments
this [ __ ] a little like he's
struggling all that YouTube money can't
buy a new shirt bro [ __ ] Ryan he's oh
don't be wearing the same [ __ ] [ __ ] of
my bottle my cam I got it like that but
my mother father softball him every time
he clapped like $200 just followed his
pocket and just as a side note you guys
want to know how you could tell I grew a
[ __ ] broke a [ __ ] if you ask a dude
that is ghetto and hetero how much he
was sucked a dick for it and that number
come out low as hell you know that [ __ ]
been broke his whole life David tell me
how much she was sucking dick for and we
go say it at the same time three million
is what let me finish cuz
but if you guys are wondering the reason
why I'm leasing a new car is because I'm
going to give my dad the car that I
bought roughly about a year ago as a
gift now this is where the story begins
now after doing a little bit of research
there was about two or three cars that I
wanted to take a look at and about a
couple of days ago I went in to go check
them out now at this dealership the
moment that I walked into the showroom I
wanted to go see somebody because I had
a lot of questions to ask about the car
and there was nobody there I looked
around there wasn't anybody behind the
desk and there wasn't anybody near the
cars so about 10 to 15 minutes passed
still nobody is coming out so I go
outside to the service area to ask
somebody if they could help me out they
said there should be somebody inside to
help you if I just wait a little longer
so I walked back in I'm chillin for
another five minutes and I see somebody
come out behind the desk behind this
door and we make eye contact so I'm
thinking the dudes gonna help me out and
by the way when I say I
I'm not talking about like a half a
second glance I'm talking about for a
solid one or two seconds like just
enough where if he was a girl I could I
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of him so he looks at
me with this kind of look and he goes
right back into the room he came out
from now mind you I'm not a pessimist
and in my mind I was thinking maybe this
dude got some things to do so he went to
the back to go ahead and finish that up
he'll be right back out anyways so
another few minutes passed I'm checking
out the cars
I hear that door open again he comes out
we make eye contact again and now he is
walking towards me so I'm like finally
this dude is gonna come out to help me
but as he's walking towards me I noticed
something a little different he was
walking towards me with the lazy little
walk his lips pursed his eyes kind of
half open kind of like this you know
that [ __ ] look I'm talking about like
I'm some low-class bug which is cool
because I'm kind of used to that but
today is a good day so I ignored that
[ __ ] I'm gonna give my dad a car I'm
looking for a new car for myself and as
I'm going up towards him during mid
greeting like this the guy [ __ ]
ignores me and he beelines it towards a
different door and he disappears again
and by the way I'm talking about
mid-sentence like this hey man how you
doing can I the [ __ ] and you know as
disrespectful as that was to walk away
from somebody as they're talking to you
mid-sentence that's not the thing that
pissed me off what pissed me off was as
I was saying that [ __ ] he [ __ ] rolled
his eyes and I'm pretty sure you guys
know what I roll that I'm talking about
it's that condescending I roll that says
you are a broke-ass [ __ ] you are
wasting my time get the [ __ ] out of here
have a look and I had a process this for
a second because I was like did I
[ __ ] do something
do you know me that I [ __ ] your mom it's
possible and in my mind I could barely
processes I was kind of like this
[ __ ] must think I still like
Dookie pies and ice cold glasses of piss
on a street corner now after having
process what just happened for the past
30 or 40 minutes I started to get a
little pissed and for those of you out
there who don't understand this let me
tell you why listen I know all too well
what it feels like to get judged from a
socio-economic point of view another one
that look that smirk that little laugh
that he did right before he [ __ ]
walked away they ignored me for another
10 minutes is something that I'm all too
familiar with
I think I'm a pretty level-headed dude
especially when it comes to situations
like this I always give people the
benefit of the doubt but if you guro
broke and as an immigrant in this
country you know that [ __ ] a look
that I'm talking about right it's that
look of number one this broke
[ __ ] doesn't have money and
number two this [ __ ] probably
doesn't speak English now once again if
you have not experiences then it's kind
of hard for you to understand but when
you see it you absolutely know it
because despite going up in a place that
was very culturally diverse I grew up
with this [ __ ] constantly and I saw
my parents go through this thing when I
was younger when I was too young to say
anything so at this point I'm a little
[ __ ] pissed but I'm still trying to
assess what's going on I still don't
want to jump into conclusions so I'm
trying to calm myself down and say hey
dude David you're [ __ ] tripping just
relax oh another few minutes pass I'm
still standing there chillin I see the
dude come out from the door as these new
customers come in by the way they're not
Asian and I'm about to say something to
him and asking him for help one more
time but he [ __ ] walks right past me
no [ __ ] eye contact and goes to them
first and ask them how they're doing and
if they need help and I don't [ __ ]
mean walk past me as if he was like 10
or 15 feet away I'm talking about the
dude walked right past me a couple
[ __ ] feet away from me BAM like that
obviously being upset I'm about to leave
this place I'm not storming out I'm just
casually going on my [ __ ] this [ __ ]
the Duke finally comes up to me and haha
he says something that [ __ ] finally
tipped me over the edge he looks at me
and it's not exactly what he said per se
but it's how he said it that finally got
me there hey buddy do you need help
oh and people who weren't born in this
country once again you know what the
wide eyes and the not and this hand
motion means when they say that to you
right hey buddy do you need help really
translates to excuse me you look like
you don't speak English so I'm gonna do
a hand motions and big eyes gestures to
help you understand what I am saying so
of course after this I could not take
the high road anymore
I was lightweight pissed so I looked at
a dead in the [ __ ] eye I walked up to
him and I said what the [ __ ] is the
whole point of you ask him if I need
help right now I've been here for
[ __ ] 30 minutes and obviously it
wasn't as composed as that because I was
so [ __ ] pissed it started like coming
out really fast why to slow my words
down so I asked dude what the [ __ ]
his problem was like I've been here for
[ __ ] 40 minutes you clearly know that
I'm here did I do something to you now
of course I'm not sure if he was
surprised as I spoke English that well
but his slouch his eyes everything was
different his demeanor change and he
goes you know what sir
I'm absolutely sorry I just didn't see
you earlier and I'm sorry if I ignored
you and that's where he [ __ ] up so you
know what the worst part about this is
when you [ __ ] up all you have to do is
apologize but instead you chose the
stupid [ __ ] route to boldface [ __ ]
lie to me
so having said that of course what did I
do
I call them out on his [ __ ] I told
him it was [ __ ] [ __ ] because you
and I obviously made eye contact a lot
earlier you [ __ ] walked away from me
as I was talking to you mid [ __ ]
sentence and you rolled your [ __ ]
eyes the [ __ ] is your problem and it's
so funny when somebody gets caught doing
something that [ __ ] up to somebody
else they quickly start to stutter or
they don't say anything at all so of
course during your signs I just told me
straight up number one when somebody
comes into your [ __ ] store and you
look at them with that [ __ ]
condescending look it's the worst thing
to call somebody buddy I am NOT your
[ __ ] child and number two if you
don't want me in this [ __ ] store I
could bounce but the fact that you
couldn't even give me the common decency
to come up to me and approach me and
then ignore me and that helps somebody
else right in front of me the [ __ ] did
you want me to do and after all that
being said he finally says I'm sorry
which is all you had to [ __ ] say in
the beginning and it's weird for me that
I had to tell somebody else was older
than me to treat someone with some
common decency and respect which is why
that I told him even if I didn't [ __ ]
speak English him doing these [ __ ]
hand motions and these big eyes is still
offensive to me we're not dumb we're not
stupid we could tell when somebody's
being condescending whether or not we
know the language and it took a solid 15
minute conversation for you to just say
one word sorry for those of you out
there they even grew up well-off or
didn't have immigrant parents let me
tell you why I get so pissed with this
typical type of [ __ ] that I had to deal
with constantly and I still deal with
till this day first and foremost you do
not get to treat us however the [ __ ] you
want based on your preconceived notion
that you are better than us [ __ ] you
you do not get to treat us like
second-class citizens because of your
perception of wealth and status
and no I'm not taking away the fact that
you have to deal with a lot of [ __ ]
customers I'm pretty sure there are
people that come in they just want to
test-drive cars or ask you questions but
guess what
that's a part of your [ __ ] job you're
a part of sales I was a part of [ __ ]
sales myself my whole [ __ ] life I
dealt with that stuff but it didn't
bother me because it was my position to
help other people but it's really not
about that is it it's not about whether
you could have made a dollar off me or
not
it was how you perceive me as a human
being in the way that you treated me
because even if you could have make a
sale off being which [ __ ] you
could have all you could have said it
was sir did you need some help if you
have any questions I'll be right over
here
if not please feel free to look around
that's it acknowledgement you dealt with
bad customers [ __ ] who the [ __ ] you
just don't get to do that to me or
anybody else without having to hear some
[ __ ]
now I already told this guy face-to-face
about this [ __ ] and I'm gonna just say
this [ __ ] in the video again you don't
get to do that [ __ ] to me because of
what the [ __ ] it took me to get to where
I'm at the [ __ ] responsibility that I
had on my [ __ ] shoulders to even put
me in this position to where I could
even buy a [ __ ] car get a car for my
[ __ ] parents and even pay rent from
my own [ __ ] place without having to
worry where the [ __ ] my next meal is
coming from I work hard for their [ __ ]
and even if I didn't I [ __ ] embody
everything there is about the [ __ ]
American dream so no sir you do not get
to treat me however the [ __ ] that you
want and you expect to get away [ __ ]
scratch-free
a lot of these [ __ ] Asian immigrants
that you probably had to deal with you
don't got to know our [ __ ] story
you're dumb
I earned my [ __ ] and I will be respected
as such that's it
you know growing up I never had a lot of
[ __ ] and you expect when you get older
that you wouldn't have to deal with this
type of things anymore especially
because you weren't hard for what you
had you don't like I never thought one
day that I'd be able to give my parents
a [ __ ] nice car and at the same time
still get [ __ ] that I actually want and
I never buy [ __ ] that I want unless is
for some kind of business purpose when
the [ __ ] like have I ever gotten
something where I was like hey you know
what dude you deserve this because you
worked hard and you try to take that
[ __ ] away from me and obviously you
don't know me so you probably wouldn't
know this but honestly I put I'd be some
[ __ ] bum ass [ __ ] on a corner
of the street
[ __ ] slinging jokes were just a
[ __ ] meal
and I'm not I'm here because of the hard
work that I'm putting into people out
there that support me that even watch
this [ __ ] channel and God you know
it's just weird man
I thought I'd be dead by now but I'm
still alive a birthday just passed yeah
that [ __ ] condescending tone and look
that you [ __ ] gave me is probably
something that you give in to a lot of
other people and I'm gonna tell you
right now
you [ __ ] don't get to
marginalize me and tell me what [ __ ]
class in corner I belonged to [ __ ] you
common decency people is not that
[ __ ] hard hey what is going on
YouTube yeah I got a little heat in this
one huh but man you know I don't get
heated like this normally but this was a
hard pill to swallow so I had to go
ahead and talk about it if you like
these type of videos if you have some
other things that you guys want to get
off on your chest let me know or you
guys can make your own videos I don't
want you guys to be quiet
I want you guys to [ __ ] speak up for
yourself man and if you're asking me
what dealership this is so you guys
won't support them I can't do that
because it's not the dealerships fault
or the you know the car brand it's that
individual that was the issue we're not
gonna go ahead and do that and I know a
lot of people on YouTube don't like to
talk like this anymore but I don't
really give a [ __ ] I've got to this is
my boys this is well how I got where I
met so you know if you guys ever
experience some [ __ ] like that you don't
have the COS scene but just know that
you're not alone speak up and be proud
of who you are don't ever let somebody
tell you that you're not worth it ah
peace out y'all that [ __ ] so reg
I bet you suck in the stomach just $200
come out as [ __ ] just pack Ryan
you don't know me but sponsor me
[ __ ] I bought a couple of days
ago I went in and I went to Mexico
oh man when he comes from a different
abominable